you
fee fie foe fum mascot wins the son
for between heaven and earth is a
perilous place home to a fearsome giant
race who hunger to conquer the mortals
below waiting for the seeds of revenge
to grow I saw your lies and I'm fast
what are you doing out in this nasty
weather your highness
these your books my father used to read
that today I like a good adventure I'm
looking for an adventure of my own what
am i dead not just yet the legends are
true
Elmont assemble a team of your best men
yes I bring back my daughter the majesty
I want to volunteer what do you suppose
she's up there
I never suppose I simply prepare for
everything
mankind have returned
there are do not remember mission is to
find and return the princess tomorrow
you shall return below with me
as your new king
I'm talking to Giants I had this jacket
I had this
let's kind of a few of them down to
South shall we another way I'll make
everything sound so simple simple phone
boy
not at all
it's jack
I won't tell better than I expected